adam thanks so much for coming on it's
i'm not in any way doubting your story
but it's i mean i used to work in
magazines i've never heard of anything
like that
did i misstate what happened
well no you were spot on tucker clearly
forbes editors did not want our
oversight of dr anthony fauci's finances
on the website and so after eight years
206 columns i estimate i wrote a quarter
million words on investigations on the
forbes platform my column was canceled
so
here's how it worked the national
institutes of health top six top
executives wrote an email to myself and
randall lane the top content officer at
forbes it was couched as a corrections
email but the corrections there was
basically no substantial corrections and
they quibbled about small things in my
column but that was the excuse that
forbes used to cancel the column
and it was that this randall lane
character who's like posing as an editor
he's the one who made this decision
so
here's how it went after that email
within 24 hours i received a phone call
from my editor at forbes that i was
barred from publishing on anthony fauci
any longer now keep in mind our
oversight was tip of the spear with
anthony fauschi a year ago we were the
ones that published that he was the most
highly compensated federal employee that
column has 900 000 views we publish the
fact that his household net worth
rivaled 11 million dollars and in 2020
his household earnings
that uh anthony fauci and his wife made
1.7 million dollars many people don't
know that anthony fauci's wife christine
grady is the chief bioethicist at the
national institutes of health she makes
more than the vice president north of
235 000 anthony fauci makes more than
the president at 456 thousand so if you
take their salaries tack on the taxpayer
paid cost of federal benefits at 30
percent the two fouchies their household
income paid for by taxpayers every year
is 900 thousand dollars
okay
you describe the whole point of
journalism is to tell people what their
government which they pay for which
claims to represent them is actually
doing and randall lane the kid in the
hat
and the rest of you know of the butt
kissers at forbes shut you down i i just
i think it's a shocking story i really
do
at a time of a lot of shocking stories
adam angiewski thanks so much for coming
on tonight